l'abbé pierre au centre de ne pas les
milk le français le plus populaire si
l'on en croit les sondages l'apôtre des
sans logis en effet semé le trouble en
confirmant son soutien aux thèses
négationnistes développé par roger
garaudy
dans son tout dernier livre les mythes
fondateurs de la politique israélienne
le point de cette affaire avec xavi
lambert une lettre de cinq pages envoyé
à un ami de quarante ans la des pierres
a pris fait et cause pour roger garaudy
l'homme d'église défend ce qu'il appelle
un livre d'honnête homme un ouvrage
qu'il n'y ne pas avoir lu entièrement
mais dont il défend la publication y
compris pour ses passages les plus
discutables pour mieux dénoncer la
politique de l'état d'israël
l'auteur donne ici ouvertement dans le
révisionnisme c'est à dire sinon la
contestation au moins la mise en doute
de l'extermination de six millions de
juifs pendant la seconde guerre mondiale
l'abbé pierre lui aussi doute aux vins
ou pour ma génération est apparu les
travées atrocités abominable de te fille
était née ziegler et de son régime
il n'est pas surprenant on était portés
à exagérer
elle sent que ce soit par malhonnêteté
mais dans la passion le service qu'on
puisse rendre le plus grand mal qu'on
peut faire une pause fait de lui
apporter des arguments exagéré
aujourd'hui en tout cas c'est la
consternation chez tous ceux qui luttent
contre la résurgence de l'antisémitisme
via la négation des crimes nazis
l'abbé pierre leur apporter une caution
loin de nous l'idée de croire que l'abbé
pierre est antisémite ou négationniste
ce serait une insulte à son combat à ce
qu'il est mais il a été peut-être
abusaient abuser de la part de gens
extrêmement record et qui se servent
aujourd'hui de sa personnalité de son
nom et puis il faut savoir que roger
garaudy non le livre fait scandale a été
communiste pendant plus de trente ans ce
qui est mise en lumière aujourd'hui ce
sont les liens entre extrême gauche et
extrême droite sur fond d'antisémitisme
c'est un petit peu le
comment le nouvel ordre économique
mondial incarnée par par les états unis
et un refus d'une solution européenne et
social démocrate hier il ya toujours ces
éléments là et pour les antisémites
c'est ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que
l'amérique représente le temple new york
c'est la principale ville juive du monde
pour eux l'abbé pierre parle aujourd'hui
d'une cabale son dernier coup de gueule
en tout cas passe mal
brigitte